[Applause]
it's so beautiful to be here like
watching that scene right now in the
back is just brought memories back from
what a beautiful life yeah no
was that really cool to be able to like
speak in your native tongue like on the
show like that's pretty cool it was the
most beautiful thing it was yeah and now
I understand what Americans feel like
when they act in English
and it's so much easier they don't do it
all the time so I thought it was really
cool and because of my Duolingo I
understood most of it
um so very proud of myself thank you
you grew up in Guatemala I did not know
this about you because my sister loves
all the Chicago she loves all these
she's the one who watches them in my
house and I'm always watching them with
her so I didn't actually know that
you're a professional soccer player
first yeah I mean I yeah sucker that
sport saved my life that was that was um
it got me through the toughest times in
my childhood and I got recruited by the
AC Milan to go to Italy to play soccer
in Italy for a while then I broke my
femur and then I shifted things and
became a martial artist and I learned
Krav Maga became a black belt in Krav
Maga are you serious yeah for real
that's so cool yeah but it is
interesting like if you if you say yes
to things that you might not have before
and then your life takes you down a
different path yes so way better life
yeah and I'm glad you did it because
you're so amazing on this show and so
when did you move to Los Angeles we were
pretty young right yeah well I was eight
I was born and raised in Guatemala and
at 18 after doing all these things and I
wanted to maybe go to Israel to the Army
um
I I was like I don't know what to do you
know and I I was I was sitting in that
red light with my mom right true story
and she's like yeah what should we do
you know you tried the soccer thing you
tried the craft of God like what can we
do and she was like what you like movies
don't you
and I was like yeah yeah like movies
what do you mean I like movies yeah
Everyone likes movies she was like why
didn't you do that and I was like what I
love your mom yeah she's just like sure
yes my mom is my angel and she was and
she and she literally told me that and I
was like well how do you do that and she
was like well I guess you moved to
Hollywood right
I love you Mommy and she was like where
is that I was like it's in Los Angeles
yeah so
she said she said to me you know like
Brad Pitt like he packed his car and he
packed his bags and he went to Hollywood
do that
and I was like most parents are like
have a backup plan for real yeah and we
just shook it and we're like we're going
to Hollywood I love it yeah and I called
the airline that day and I never went
back for 10 years
um one-way ticket you're always gonna
have to have to believe in yourself
because you had such a great mother to
instill that in you too because she had
so much belief in you that what a
beautiful mother you have I am the story
of a single mother
of my angel that is my story oh my God
yes I I you would welcome here anytime I
just cried almost okay we're fine
so tell everybody
well I played Dante Torres
AKA ocean and he is uh
he comes from a tough environment but
he's always maintained his heart and his
Integrity is what he is and he knows
exactly who he is he's not a people
pleaser at all and he will do right but
what he believes 100 all in all the time
you know great characters it's a
beautiful care I was blessed to have
this beautiful character and he stopped
me so much to me like I've learned so
much from him you know so cool yeah so
lot of my staff is actually from Chicago
no joke and they say that there's
something called a Chicago handshake yes
and I I have experienced that I have
something for you okay is this the
Chantry is this what it is yes the shot
of malort what's a mallor what's some
what's my Lord my Lord is uh is it a
type of alcohol okay um from Chicago
that I oh you can only drink this if
you're cool okay all right no peer
pressure
so I drank it in Chicago because it's
cool like that okay and I think you're
cool I'm pretty cool I think so tell
everyone what we do here this is the
this is the shot of my Lord okay then we
Chase it down with beer you do the shot
new it's a chaser yeah and then we shake
on it and now we're cool together okay
time
you don't need a chaser
that's good
I don't think I needed a chaser oh it's
still hot going down for me it's like
very bitter it's like very bitter right
I don't know I think it's like people
like you like beets or you don't like
certain things like certain like do you
think that's an acquired taste no I just
handle it
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]